when you watch media right now who do  you trust  I wouldn't put all my eggs in one to ask  it one way or the other there's very few  people who bring the meat potatoes I  think a journalist is somebody that the  more division there is the more money  they make let's just face the truth and  who holds them accountable do we hold  people accountable for exercising their  freedom of speech we have a relationship  you're the expert I'm not the expert I  don't have time to go run a research and  do everything your facts can all be  right but the story is still wrong the  truth is somewhere in the middle right  people are addicted to their outrage  they want to be angry every day I think  would freak the average person how to  have their emotions removed from their  political beliefs  that's like tearing someone's religion  or whatever you have the emotion not you  the journalist I don't want you to have  the emotion I want the journalist to  tell me the truth  you  [Music]  you